do you go home thanks for introduction and
will i happen to be you i'm going to
talk about what if you can arise and
that a sound system software engineers
collaborate in that pim tensen
publications and some bottoms that
reformed can be used to addresses
so knew  also how the beat from my point of
view
as the software engineer that becomes gas
closely with data scientist
in the variety of great great nou a
working for sale something like the risk
e-commerce website where we do
how if it is spent for instance too
expensive commendations of large texts this
is actually people can tank
my vest also was 3 years ago in pwt
again walked on eat also soon have
private and i go to sleep a good sign that
the prototype from zo peter
notebooks
only way into production so drowsy  and he
goes worked on building know that
blew out
billink depa is hey development of tools
to support data scientist and
researchers in ascii out of quest house again
and so experience read and or did arie
little tiger reforms pro nintendo lin
text en daleks words and with boffin
startup zo medium-sized companies and
those zo
in freelancing zo rond talking about
collaboration
it is interesting to think that
collaboration between and see first
oil that cool simple tap is a rudy
picto [ __ ]  there she when she built to
facility from friesland fashion
control for that frame programming
paradigm
leak waterfall agile scrum with cetera and
do some specialized frameworks for
instance
were developed which has been quite a
week went before for the bas blekkingh
not us so info civilization that  him or
engineers who is the fence kids
bin and front-end cool not the
collaborate on let's kill product and
dorking
parallel how would the block allow something
else they come goal as it opens is
in my hand
and later as web development  is it
becoming mainstream
frameworks and path and started two words
to facility that vouch for voice
model-view-controller
if there is ne  e that you as separate and the
frameworks seem tango and floated
so we splash is this wet paper wood or
veneer
picasso before the web there was also
desktop software zo x oil
baby excavation widgets and event listener
dates from bake wim with it wax adapter
for  the change i requirements of to
grab
about shelf and i drove now this the then
gave internally that the three their applique sometimes
that there is becoming joep i went and
running now that the site is a software
engineer slept to work efficiently
together with gold blok in  each other
so what happens is there us also patrons
and marriage and business eibli
huge evolutionary process so up
some issues and when redness and find
solutions and when some solutions and does that
work and do that work again that kit picked up
or adapter and runs with  maybe
body something good about him became in
savers and external race still solution
so in that the ribbon applique is sometimes mega
of in your element
how it is really like to explore the
daten
how would it grapping i touch i learn is
fix was in web development
it's the problem space is narrower
how long dudes die time website management
so with change things and this mix asper
up stink that's called that exploration has
some more fixin' come how e-  con
pension richard
the same but it anyway the many walked
through me that the house
vinckx come into liesbos
well
because talking about what the data scientist
iso the software engineer ge works in
details already clear-cut definition so
he measures mahjong
something pangang  to work with for the rest
whether it is also so
kanpai rings data scientist and at
software engineer
networks we see the body
that friend mo tvs him he that friend
cor competencies that of the interest
likes and dislikes and diferent tunes sets the
two hours
like this  in from where people and gift
smokes weed and yet
babies would rather cost something or something speakers share
soap people patrick at the end of tomorrow he
starts with a u know he ten to see
advice the site is e  r beautiful you should know
by gathering of only always of the
dating how there is software engineer sr
mostly motivated by the goal of
designing and built and building and
robust data management systems system
and the third site is charlie Koeltas king
again out quest will date him  and who
there prating western and engineers aurelie
pants
yes the bim building and maintaining
component in the ddr pipeline
seems databases courses chatter and
making sure that big o this production
grading
that the site is ten to read about to do a
specific research so for instance
read  about 2 context again the
commendations
software engineer is in data read about
how did a management systems village and
per'aps get the bit more in-depth
in two internal of the systems
that the site is a bite see the note
I spending time the  barking lowlevel and
rose and software engineers gay robbers
tournament automated line of work
such a walk with other speak at other
people's throw and that the scientist'
with  your more inclined to pc too complex
model that do i would not be able to be
formulated at the stem
i got the issue sam smart then
formulates a proof and the software
badges
the occasional feber moral side code notes
with c and d
how the respect  it uns that the his fish
vibrate used to pieter notebooks
he is cuelen in week did frameworks
and the software engineer students use
more the command line that she was your ipad
and notebooks pad
european office whatever want in line
with the right but they also use
clothe  frameworks like me see these
two different look the smallest people and
on three you are meter iq that friend who
had some stuff income but wants to admit
dave there is a scene core competence and
winter is so showed well what is your
scanner journey how a  at work together
to built that the three winamp liquer sometimes
so and to teapot him that can go home
is that t we this is between each
gave then let or too mate xs to date
so because of this don't know al  s i
somebody to to get with it manually export
or dating to work om
how is which can be used for both
parties or en who gave complete freedom
to run who exploits riquewihr isam
2 production offender is so on a sled
bouvy scenario would problem the  kiss the
site is now not to be able to work
independently and fresh dating and bag big
data sets and flush with world like the
lead breakdown 2 production system
so talk and toe address wrong is the usa
replicas
and dtp and docs oil like a human
before time
boiling frog 3ds smell like in twinlife
is a hot air waybill thing that
abs system
we experts go the gland division between
database systems that there is good for
online transactions and processing
food as order processing in a
modern website and the quiz and  de that that
business that is precisely for online
analytique and processing
how the cc moore of age 1 euro stolen
turkey and data scientist ooh so
erase his known issue how the huge
solution  web they use upload gave dcm
data base for bof you can go we a
replica or the more data base for running
analytic cookies and easy to make
sense replica can die as soon as
the french keyboard layout
facility so chris wouldn't you
admit to think about gold  fish in a
modernize two
and die so review half eat though yucca
nut those waxing chairs date it is on
the people who benefit from levy an
e-piano inch further flamingo escuela for
some other reason it is important to
think about building the detail you have
so another issue that can arise
he consent d from reading or two
algorithms just fishing third sign that did stand
out
so there is also attitude dress and jason and
you see is that flexlease or for in sometimes it
is hard to find out if we change a
moving in which direction what effect that
is pretty cool ebury salt and you see go
to talk to what is happening
no i don't how cool emily's doctor with
gold the weekend him with some input 2012
i would rather i be or ve  rkoop
and then we that the site is spend a lot of
time producing reports for different
combinations of inputs and come something where
you make him some mistakes in the
percent leading to restart in set the
frisbee to measure
alex oil this is something to go and
bar a single i long time in one of my
previous shows
who goes the graff dat zambo this is there
food the foregoing for gay and he
wants strike to generate this the
discount through the ass and this was that pc and
daewoo is with summertime  trying to find
out what is a clip was the french was
it this views the different but see
how the different day time confit does
what was it
he student still that do it is kebab
if yes to the data site is so civilization
problem in coagulation  be those pendants
is now at machines will go sideways
so reports end
that distribution they understand breaking chains
in well that is the room couple
entry suffered in the process leak pushing
customer since ages get some number
shaved  then also make such
so the pattern how to check it here path
what you good want to house party and one
way to keep track of wazzhappening has
increased 3 really easy to it and reed
reports
in the control enviroment my goal is
automatique lee for every comet  so
your office aggression I test so you
can check out the songs download igor
exploration lek see what is your date
exploration look like
how and you are it thumping in some
other parts of the code the cost for
grissom fortress this is b&s grete die
full-  time the collecte propreté so it
and is ever also in this self
concurrence donna bell winter who soon will buy
then with it then beat m going
to present
now spc
week use case in spite from one of my
previous positions and faithful humanist to
keep  knew organized and that your body
one-click report so what we go as road
eat though
sensor dating that guy was
from people balotelli
en imprint doing some processing
weeee tried to eat some torture he
balk citizens 3 contract detector is
so
encourage you in the cloud cb data pipeline
who actually garde at least two
different immense script and how solid
when ie your database
based on it parameter and there is and
how you go immense crypsis blush
fascinate
who were working  with a mixed and
collaborators with we really good your
painful loss specific problem
and we want you top of the film so
the village who were in it how is the
process that is it how around the wax oil
create
reports because trees old for a joint
is something really long hadderingh corpse
he is the person changing out of this good
for instance with shaking make sense
for joy kiss and will proceed with
closer to reality to the previews
therese mrs gray black bent
reconstruction was doing well and in that
jent what do you want  the
anesthesia became people because it to be the
ring
flexible what we that rtm week here gouwy
upline sam report to pores and the output
with ho  e that kind of middle to be
reorganize with whom we running
the pipeline pierre at the cloud
we ever admitted it into a man it is
a phenomenon you because it is t to see the
pipeline to be connected populi so input
output and want so has it  is a
previous input is notes and rete
logical then because they steeles in oldenzaal
coupe
and they also keep track of of profane
slack what i saw now what inputs
what come something i what parameters
are responsible for creating we your
keyboard on intermediate outputs
and then we will  there was were challenge or
estimates marlowe big ass who should be
and chaos since the camp
thumping or in mix simmer the kind of
dissolution
was that the third site is how is
the market running carriage not going to
accelerate then you want it cool that me
and wim  that's end is how it create
father data scientist at no prive and
must great bay reports mans if
templates was here is boring and hepie and
from away
web development worn and when we software
engineers m  oet image the d-day pipeline
out or the component we still find lady at
the data scientist seperate wrinkles
and keep track or two acts provinz and
am how i'm talking about reapered who
triggers automata shine something comet
by way louis v how have interface
and kip populated at the date from we
did Pijplijn and tommy smit as soon as
these reports came to be
anyway and i simple how did it looks
like the cc is the oil slightly modified
screenshot or what who goes with
pieter vis so one i want  who could use
that for at night no the city your
review who lives the to create and report
look cheap and here is that so who goes
the tour spoons the revs connect and will
you can check you can on input task to
iteration around for  pepper dream that en
repel toe
you can also input suggested you
live is in salt
men you could test them nice dating sets
nvm
you can select for to apply
and what it works corpse of the data site
is boring
sorry just how you  hit  t goes green the
period go for sale at the top how did
they go they were can be
run over bye bye bye plein and wim beek
and huxley drive whatever they want
to explore the process daten find earth
well is normal and the tick  join because
and district calling it's okay that's it we
input always improvise ar
local place in pipeline again so
least we love that so hive is the
hole samsam pull the output
70 firm see wicked axel i use that does
that a lot on the report
wat as soon as they upload this
2organize framework got your skin
math beer on
in my organized reagents te production
dh sorry that we je flexibly cast
tape die wel op
locally and when used with online en
axel i used to pieter en op books as
templates requires  the glass motor skills
i something to whom while blue berry she
15 support for generating hottest in my
brother my notebook
it's nice and dark again apply
parameters is notebook
like to use it as a rule template to
grea  t different age game will fight for
the fruit inputs
what those costs isn't dr so this path
and gas oil you notice that boy
wants anyway about para with rice
notebooks there was a reason i don't go
it's so hard that  end but your
fork to be tent limit is so that
we can still only with private lease what
it is like was still possibilité previews
person and still waiting to be human
so int what this we software engineer
team do but who is going to do that fork
when i went to school stick together
advantage web interface how you go and
flask web server in the salary cool that
does
nipples with carey gates touch and
process dam and though she climaproof and
lothric to keep track of problems which
was basically well kees chest and gas  or
for basic weekend parameters that play
the role in are the rating and output and the
soy
partnership a sith that the bag tap
according to the inputs we committee guests
are the parameters and trained and
troops to notebook
with patty jobs lucy was stable
kent from scratches using salary and
flask
what in hindsight i used to be
cellphones friends quiz in poland makes sense
to use existing building blocks and
kies became a lodge we go continuous
is integration flow and when
dat the pipeline system  black airflow
luigi so far is a growing
where speakers there is no cowmates lab
support for weaving
with fridge so oh good god peace
stock how good faroese time and that
may be to take too much effort to meet
with around with measles and box so that
in florida wheatley  the emergency exact
body death disease keep track of
lawrence he gave x-pack letting you his
race and whether pipelines managers
want is the course is really important and
people in webforms and of leather bag
king about
soldier one touch of designing we
workflow like with the  is the two
perpetrators it's over control of terror
corps and week after it was new
how would it interference ajax elite
right to ha  ve it in the prima sees resem
though it was really fixed what weather the
port could be
it is in word pike's changing
require mens
he said huck solid know what to check
the coast at that site is arie van bi'j
oons who actually know  what's up with
questions
how is the post was if they date something like that
will both matter dear web access
my d mandates a swan or the wrinkles
that can see what happens in the report
and the exactly code look and the weather
routines
is that how i gave  check or against data
without any problems and leg or arm and to
airport south a reason so superfluous can
god it's so web interface and check at
prograss oh my god i have to go again soon
real beauty lot or surprise
others don't even comfort him like that toilet theo
that he mother queen willing and action
he knew resting became the people i really
special leader nodes were applied in
the way was found inside the company
this axel i went well so
we take away from van with potter that
he lives you to thin  k about is the film
what have taken dt pipeline
you need to locate sighing parts that
not to be strictly men with
social parts
how we that site is provides access
freedom to explore the dating and then it
would chain bogged down the barking
library deep  intentions connect your
databases et cetera
so I you don't want to always
thumping together of your own that yellow leg goes
you can knew what the community played in
management framework no bluebiz
workflow so or and I still have to
see man wet t quite  like
is that nothing who positions oxley design
to that notebook and 3-port creations
so this is the main focus
11e or framework and deep they go
frame again the user interface will be
counters tysk en des lands class trus
experiment and turn it listen then
do you need old and new ink and eye wooden
sheds monastery business uncle honest and
when it also has a good epa
and three is an animal cell airflow support
then we give software engineer stable
the pipeli  ne
wat buzzer bast
so effective you want to address that
channel eyes when people i work with
notebook she runs is the foil left can
help so
varices of scm cold or a slightly
modified code there
leaving in several notebooks i get and
duplicate in in eyes vs  or corsican
snail more link to in Noordbroek and c can
you scopie pace with some times with
we see people drive code that is the voice a
function that testers have a briefing and am
it
is far point is i blow him
gates with maybe you know  the supervisor
ie in 13 off with this could be fine
[music]
so that this is my idea could be to
have at least one team member insight to
see that's it to be there
he was so cool software engineering just
so that ruby ​​with  disperse him now to that
situation roster we do another
view free code
zoë you shiver in follows in code reviews
there provide your mouth and the
winner frequently used patterns and
when creating mojo scoutfm
and when i lead by example in  a co2
so mee binen code review we can say hey
you using with pink twice or the single
bedstead of fictions in baseline glad with
you can just more the fiery sunset de
fruiting the beginning and the law quiz lonely
week high quality kortbeek and in taste
our op  to building how
influence trank define the levels of
abstraction
lucas pandas that the frames are purple
park hear so grab that the weird and
really great with
if i think about it busy blowing and
lowlevel coupons this is an
alice tomato what what the details
so the bindings  and what do here love
dating
haps you can make some class is with
abstract even more information and they
tomorrow on the street
we go you there productivity and bbq
you so stupid kit bogged down by the tales
and love and I tick the course that son
of  de libische hattems
we christians schouten find exactly how
to implement them for something as you
could be do here roda jc
there is still short cut about you need to
have pee-pee go on it in the singers or
copy  the cases with each other
so admitted interdisciplinarity links
between perpetrators are his engineering and
then soap operas
ficus in lead or stuff this my room
later oil this panel
presentation
how there people praesent we tunes that he
along and the transfer notes about is for
a  behold to use get better city
seemed
and the interior to cut uv too cold
chocolate race so what a meme with you
what so this is my person opinion that
woodhouse how hot emilie meetingselect
is where we try to design architecture
and sometimes gray
get coating die  taylor framework korps
je vriens dongle how but you think
educate something lily kon fusing black
with some times square and not think
band gave is meetings' en single
instead of only focus then see
different components in soft coeur
stok interact brussels i to be thinking
about our different teams interact
sophie profit was how i m haver
meetingselect is
so out and whether fischeri de boer and gwen
met bij de trieste  fit is what at le
barge there is a law week and that we
just access actions to production
pico's something incontinent for it him
then that does not work
and we him the focus is listening and
sixth dwyer how you can choose that your
production were strong clean
this  is the workaround that their song
do it bit more easily
no ludo sabina is admitted more
meetingselect is though how you
state before this collaborates how
sambal that rotates quite
really bad golden collaboration pack
it seems this is actually
small flat happening to wayne  rooney and
are you going to torture the external carburetors
that with you experts in torturing
okay anyway relax pot of gold
and how you keep track of or of their
progress
how to get our country to him melis who
would grab before the coffee flows then
think about  it can happen like that
how can i reconcile the email server idea how
to receive free bes10 trial and
if so
and when behind brings flow like
ok what tv provider www peter vr  ees that
the wii controller week and evaluate how
sweet had to actor korvinus
watkins that's the fat who is going to be like that
and the torino mixsense for all grammy
read ok so with blades was so much fun
to talk about
i think is said then left to take  away
one of them is they want you
want to be or ink all your others are
so big and throw presentation
checkpoint too deep stealing ideas from
previous day games or other software
engineer to find solutions then my
problem so he caught user that  and
per second
the side and who is that data driven
applique sometimes not to be designed for
flexibility in exploration
otherwise the emotion barracks and happen
but
so you drunk guys here so far keep
resolute foundation
the kid did this orgonite and lid i
glued to be foul
[Applause]
think so much for protection caroline
floor of a dos provence touch your free
single servicing and our position
eelding cils salary one ring in
this site is downright tired prior to the
notebook the kids support audio or
keys parameters in the goods from
users to those flask web applications
ok you anyway actually be ben pkvw
streamline process for led how not
to think handles  gps a your para mi
can we t the sidewalk old bad pico's in
lyceum templates chicano choppa fight
and he nothing in the house
your file the two you can work with fat
with bee so that your anger does not change it
into many places you steal it to change'
10v word interface part of even one
green key view have john piece track
jeeptour dashboards and i like that
he also becomes spinning for such a port so
easy inverse thank you for the
presentation
but krishna is inside
essie the focus your of your presentation
is more  of a black worship en de
renalis and napoleon all is ben
actually contact us for simple
winsum sister assign teams quadratum
engineers but focus free sample to
this pr  oduct free sample is wrongly in the cell
via analyzing debtor
building tools for two analyzed and it
comes to certain situations where a free
sample bleaching types of metrics free
sample of shirt a tool is bulters
specific situation and the leader free
sample minutes integrate there a product
is the bad guys
third the province consult the third
signed with to verify the accuracy of my
my passion is also a replay theo de
strengt 15 free sample moment comes the
situations where
and you were single the software engineer
teams worker tuning the pipeline it
self true  is the other side seam is
probably more focused on the accuracy of
filling and then all the technical reviews the
machine will force the politicians through
so that the revenue situations like
having percent le bacq in production and
the driving the fack set the software
engineers knowledge  the tripe in
solving door jump fris en zo he drink
one way to keep track of the sith go
before i read it test  we know the
site is not access and there is poopy
for
for is a css lead in ww2 günther face
to dan
glass and tests forever i come i
like the nolet work
coach agree lead breaking
something
it raw or christian and beebikes with
happen microsof something in production
that data scientist koen
dies anticipée de maize there 16 merry whiskeys
with whom
you are typical official access
somebody' from the software engineering
team that is axel in the form
wii fit data science team would somebody
who is there something  special those two
teams i saw you
joe offered for this position lucas people
are starting trio list with be supported
how i got
it with search engines want
operator at dan de
je someone in the journal commerce and
communication and having
mitchell presentations at nos curious  if
you in my title what you just become other
things have seen work would have
seen at work
ok is about a scene throw is that t
how and how it the  sign thing and
architecture who gave representatives of
above have a genius ring that the
science team that prism
lucas benw pitchers in the title or the
data science team can chf you hurt that
hey everyone got stuck at prevented from
working en from getting you
out  in a better way and some other links
that needs work and or internal
training sessions with an other i
wrote is that t baby is sufficient also
wants something her ria peace of breaking
stuff so wwb en the cry in public there
most somehow something like that is better  to do
something training and sometimes because every
review gave then with a series lina
foundation something while blue so that baby
hallmark of fitdance in using mean
one left as measured using t decided to
become an average pace of engineer's if
it's not a job so he quite  about bodysuit
play to their strengths and what the
axle i want to learn
them for intensive that the site is wants
to learn operations en dokker when they
shoot with he app see what we case  is
het bos do public on
becomes some people do not want to so poor
het cot you can you can to some extent
tried to be better at what you're
interested in bigger than you will be
more more to know
with quiver wants to become  with the
software engineer and [ __ ] exchanges suitcase
from the coast that to religious on
ah no sorry no honey i miss my boot
cut quality you
could send that jamie jack complete
so that when i also the people ronaldo
an idea from the general
grant sometimes things are different  me history and
they the site is a relative runners
no cuz that we do my first the coach mail
with be too if you have one my function
under the sea briefing
wine and can sit with you and so you
might together and love you can do with  the
extract
promotions lines of code talent into four
functions and we nexttime you can go for
functions may be you cam show you how to
make a we tomorrow a your position
reconsider extreme merge into jeans en
toe these services team where it consist
o  f cost whether this site is and did
ingenious where can do something right now
your is the have team he became ajam in
he peak it to be girl dear aj was not
the only software engineer for instance
with the business card or the setup
do you think caroline  no shopkeepers whine